&gt;&gt; You might be wondering, why should we even learn elimination to begin with?
Well, would substitution really work here? Would it be a good choice? Well, I
could take this first equation and try and solve it for either x or y. Remember,
for substitution we're trying to get one of the variables alone on one side of
the equation. I'm going to solve this equation for x. I subtract 3y from both
sides to get 2x is equal to negative 3y minus 15. I just list these terms,
because they're not like. Then we divide both sides by 2, so x is equal to
negative 3 halves y minus 15 halves. Notice that this equation is a little
complicated. We have two negative signs, and we also have fractions. So when
we're working with substitution, this could make our work more difficult. Keep
in mind though, that when we perform substitution, we don't have to just solve
for x. We could have solved this equation for y. I could subtract 2x from both
sides, to get 3y equals negative 2x plus 15. Then I would divide each term by 3.
So, 1y would equal negative 2 3rds x plus 5. If I wanted to use this for
substitution, it's still pretty complicated. We have a fraction and we have a
negative sign. So let's try instead using elimination. When solving this system
using elimination, I'm going to try and eliminate these x variables. I could
choose to try and eliminate the y variables. It doesn't actually matter. I'm
going to multiply this first equation by 5. So I get 5 times 2x, which is 10x, 5
times 3y, which is 15y, and 5 times negative 15, which is negative 75. I
multiply this equation by 5, so that way I could get a 10x here. So what number
should we multiply this 5x by, so that way we get a number here that would
eliminate with the 10x? Take some time to think about it.